let's talk about my leg amongst other
things she's known for sticking her
tongue out all the time like all the
time we're measuring everyone's tongue
on the red carpet here to see if they
have a longer tongue than her you had to
guess how big do you think Miley's
tongue is he's pretty good-sized so
Miley's known for her long tongue write
you a sixer tongue that's definitely
what she's known for us yeah so today we
wanted to acknowledge that by measuring
everyone on the red carpets tongues so
we'd love to measure your tongue
I need to make sure that yours isn't
longer than her yeah you want to measure
from inside or outside the mouth
let's put it in your mouth then how deep
are you gonna go how would people you
happy how deep do you want to go I want
to go all the way down under this Donna
yes this person it's rapping you can
unwrap it if you're actually going to
occur now there's on their sterile
they're clean
let's see how if that's what we're about
to find out up to you enough for me and
a black Nonna button is on right now
yeah really record should we grill that
that's like a two and a half inch on
solid oh right that looks like a to
enter right there it's all the time
that's what it is I'm so thankful for a
solid time wow that's a three-inch
tongue that's a solid BT tongue right
right Rebecca Rebecca
that looks like an treated water that's
a sarena quarter that number to
represent anything else on me Wow what
are you good that's the biggest I've
ever been Wow it's about 1 and 3/4
inches 1 or 3/4 if not the biggest
tongue we've seen it's a petite you two
and a half two and a half I might have
been to three quarters yeah let's go
down what I think that looks like a
Tudor doing this wall attraction thank
you thank you yeah I hating the brag but
I've got what it takes
Wow I love it you can go home now longer
yeah really extend okay that's like a
two in a corner yeah I think you guys
have tied tongue Keith what do we have
there
oh my god that's a four inch to 4 that's
a 4 that's a your or your leader right
now how do you feel listen number one
you saw me to win the pieces in our
shredded while I'm on the grown man
going to eat me and tell me what my
lease is later yes if we get a hole if
you can help us get ahold of her to
measure her tongue that would be a dream
come on soldier down to measure later if
you guys don't get her that'll work